chantal paoli texier présidente de
agissez à maurepas association contre le
harcèlement moral association
association contre le harcèlement au
sein de la famille un également est
l'invité du 7 8 pour débuter cette
édition avec une mauvaise nouvelle on
vous avez reçus l'an dernier vous aviez
reçu le prix femme actuelle un prix qui
vous récompenser pour l'action que vous
menez et puis la vivacité de votre
association est aujourd'hui la situation
est beaucoup plus compliquée on va
regarder un chiffre ou bien comprendre
l'ampleur du problème 14 1900 c'est le
montant en euros que vous avez reçus
pour l'association depuis le début de
l'année à la même période l'an dernier
c'était 48 1300 euros il manque presque
trente mille euros cette année comment
ça s'explique
la perte du mécénat puisque l'année
dernière on avait quand même quelques
prix il y avait une formidable il y
avait une somme assez conséquente
et puis surtout la les baisses quand ce
ne sont pas les
la coupe carrément de des subventions
c'est à dire que nos subventions en
règle générale ont été coupées par deux
donc diminué de moitié et puis il y en a
une qui a été refusé don berna beau jeu
aujourd'hui justement les subventions
sont versées par qui conseil régional
horse actuellement on a des subventions
du sdf du conseil régional du conseil
général sdf si le service le
je vais avoir du mage
services d'accès aux droits des femmes
et à l'égalité
et qui dépendent du droit des femmes en
fête et en fait ça a été notre premier
subventionneurs ça a été celui qui nous
a toujours soutenus depuis déjà pas mal
d'années et on a eu la surprise de voir
notre subvention coupée en deux donc ça
déjà ça a été déjà la mauvaise nouvelle
du printemps et puis les mauvaises
nouvelles de la rentrée c'est le conseil
général qui pareillement à diminuer sa
subvention puis le fpd qui a annulé
celle qui nous versaient et on attend
des nouvelles du conseil régional en
espérant qu'ils maintiennent ou qu'ils
augmentent notre subvention mais on
question pour les initiales de la fff
les alors c'est l'accès en fait
c'est l'accès au droit c'est le soutien
aux associations je ne peux pas vous
dire exactement le sait beaucoup
comprennent bien ce justement les
réserves du single mais ce sont des
idées des
subventionneurs qui sont là pour
justement dynamiser le milieu associatif
c'est pas propre à votre association non
c'est pas une sanction contre
l'association second vers le travail qui
est mené non non nous on est passé à
travers la première vague de baisse des
subventions de 2011 où c'est vrai que
les grosses associations a été touché de
plein fouet donc on nous disait bon
puisqu'on n'a pas de trop grosses
subventions peut-être qu'on va passer à
travers la tornade et puis cette année
non nés ne sommes pas passés à travers
la terre vous avez trois salariés nous
avons trois salariés qui sont encore
payés actuellement alors qu'ils sont
encore payés actuellement on va pouvoir
tenir jusqu'au mois de mars on ne sait
pas si on pourra continuer donc on a
vraiment besoin de cette somme d'argent
pour pouvoir tenir et assurer les tous
les projets qui sont en train de se
dérouler à l'association parce que on
est
on a énormément de projets comme dirait
ma collègue tous nos voyants sont au
vert on a un livre en cours on est très
sollicité par les médias sur des
documentaires spécialisé sur la violence
morale ou souvent appel à vous voit
partout et les médias nationaux et 2
aura certes un peu le l'effet de la
femme formidable 1 ça c'est sûr que ce
prix là nous avons c'est assez paradoxal
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de vous et
pour autant il manque des sous dans les
caisses concrètement il ment combien
aujourd'hui bas à peu près quinze mille
euros pour pouvoir tenir cette année et
faire les tous les projets
et mener à bien tous les projets que
nous avons entre autres on a un projet
de proposer des formations
qu'ils commencent à se mettre en place
on a déjà vendu une sur notre antenne de
lyon
donc on va il faut qu'on ait le temps de
pouvoir promouvoir ce
projet là qui peut être une manne
financière mais voilà qui qui n'est pas
encore fait un appel aux dons on a on
fait un appel aux dons sachant que l'on
vient d'être enfin reconnu d'utilité
générale donc ça va nous permettre de
pouvoir délivrer des reçus fiscaux ce
qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle dans
cette période assez sombre alors d'avoir
une réduction voilà augmentation tout à
fait qu'ils incitent peut-être plus
facilement à l'eau j'ai donné pour vous
puissiez récolté 7 15000 euros la
'deadline' la limite vraiment pour vous
c'est en mars 6 en mars les choses ne
vont pas mieux et vous n'avez pas réussi
à récolter ces quinze numéros voudrait
fermer l'association oui oui parce qu'on
pourra plus subvenir aux salaires et si
on ne peut pas subvenir aux salaires
nous on peut plus fonctionner avec que
des bénévoles c'est pas possible moi je
suis encore bénévoles on a des bénévoles
aux antennes on a des bénévoles au
conseil d'administration mais pour faire
fonctionner l'association
professionnellement il nous faut des
salariés etc sans ses salariés
l'association meurt donc donc voilà
lorsqu'ils sont ces salariés juste me
ressemble à personne spécialisée pour
recueillir les témoignages et des l'idée
il ya un premier poste emploi tremplin
parce que ce sont des emplois tremplins
des emplois aidés par l'état qui est une
chargée de communication qui a été notre
notre première démarche parce qu'il nous
fallait quelqu'un
auprès de qui on pouvait déléguer tout
ce qui était de me démarche de
subventions démarches auprès des médias
et c'est donc la chargée de
communication elle est essentielle à la
vie de notre association est le deuxième
emploi tremplin qui est très récent
c'est une conseillère sociaux juridiques
qui est déjà qui était déjà à
l'association en tant que bénévole
depuis des années mais qui maintenant
voilà est devenue salariée
et qui effectivement accompagne les
victimes et sans elle c'est pareil on ne
peut pas continuer on avait quelques
images de vos logements c'est là-bas que
vous recevez les abeilles les personnes
qui sont en détresse est victime de
harcèlement on peut peut-être préciser
l'objet précis à qui vous vous adressez
alors on s'adresse aux victimes de
violences morales et donc la violence
morale comprend la manipulation la
violence psychologique et le harcèlement
donc on a des gens de toute la france
qui nous téléphonent pour avoir sa ps3
robe rose évelyne annoncé pas à travers
toute la france non on nous appelle de
toute la france nous sommes d'une
association nationale c'est vrai qu'on
travaille particulièrement sur les
yvelines et sur l'île de france mais
nous nous sommes d'une association
nationale avec deux antennes una réveil
et une à lyon et on espère pouvoir un
ouvrir d'autres mais bon si on ferme sa
sera voilà projet sera caduque mais donc
on accueille on accompagne les victimes
on les aide au positionnement on les
aide à retrouver
confiance en elles leur place au sein de
cette famille qui est quand même
les structurer et puis on a ouvert aussi
un pôle qui est intéressant et j'ai bien
peur que l'on soit aussi obligé de le
fermer c'est que actuellement on
développe l'accueil et l'accompagnement
aussi des enfants et adolescents avec
des groupes de parole donc on est
inscrits aurait appuyé par exemple
c'est la réunion de toutes les
associations qui développe
des gouttes des actions en direction des
enfants et des parents voilà donc on a
des groupes de paroles parentalité pour
faire face quand on est parent à la
violence conjugale c'est extrêmement
difficile et compliqué surtout la
violence morale parce que c'est une
violence qu'on n'arrive pas à nommer
donc on a besoin de vraiment apprendre à
la verbaliser apprendre à la dire
apprendre à la à l'identifier donc on a
en fait cet accompagnement pour les
adultes mais on a aussi développé cet
accompagnement pour les enfants donc s'y
plier les aides vous développer encore
de nombreux projets on va juste faire
une pause partir dans les rues de saint
quentin en yvelines aujourd'hui notre
question du jour quelles solutions pour
lutter contre les violences familiales
on vous écoute et puis on poursuit
l'entretien donc avec la chantal paoli
texier l'association agissez je pense
qu'effectivement il ya d'abord de
l'éducation qui est extrêmement
importante la part des parents
primordial de façon primordiale ensuite
on discutait régulièrement je pense que
la communication il ya des écoutes
normand et devrait pas avoir beaucoup de
violence et beaucoup d'amour et ben par
une attention
peut-être d'abord du voisinage parce que
ça c'est pas toujours et puis ensuite
voir des services sociaux dans la mesure
où ils sont celui sont avertis
et puis ensuite peut-être à celle à la
victime ou le victimes on sait jamais de
réagir une question d'éducation
le respect de l'autre ça commence par
part par les adultes mais les enfants
aussi les voisins les profs à l'école
etc et je pense que le premier plus
globale que purement familial
aujourd'hui je pense qu en priorité la
prévention de tout ce qui est précarité
puisque la précarité amène à la violence
fin pas forcément mais ça peut apporter
la violence de la prévention de l'emploi
des relations familiales du bien-être
des enfants je pense que tout ça passe
par un bien-être
familial la violence est engendrée par
le par le mal être
et votre avis sur ce qu'on vient
d'entendre c'est un petit raccourci
clavier vrai stratège ont vu par le mal
être
il ya des choses qui sont très très
juste alors je reprend l'idée de la
prévention c'est c'est quelque chose qui
nous tient beaucoup à coeur on sait
d'ailleurs émis s'est plusieurs fois
dans des
dans des essais de prévention on veut
continuer à le faire parce que ça nous
paraît important je pense
qu'effectivement il faut commencer à
éduquer les jeunes au respect
que ce ne se reproduise pas ce qui est
en train de se produire le problème de
la violence morale c'est qu'on est dans
un domaine d'emprise on est dans un
domaine de domination et de prise de
contrôle donc une violence qui
traiterait invisible crédit qui est très
indicible et qui du coup peut sévir
extrêmement longtemps avant que
quelqu'un s'en aperçoive
donc oui il ya des recours on peut
effectivement aller voir les assistantes
sociales on peut aller voir les
associations surtout parce que c'est
leur nécessité voilà 10h12
le rapport d'amnesty international en
2005 précisé que le gouvernement
français donc c'était un rapport
critique sur le la façon dont la france
gérer
la prise en charge des violences
conjugales à porter une critique sur
enfin demandé plus tôt au gouvernement
de donner les moyens aux associations de
pouvoir continuer leur action
voilà donc et on sent la nécessité de
vos actions on sent aussi qu'il ya une
forte demande parce que les appels sont
en forte augmentation pour l'association
oui on a multiplié par deux notre
chiffre d'appel par rapport à 2011 la
salade après vous vous avez reçu depuis
alors là avec l'arrêt de juillet de
juillet 2 et 2 août on en est un 1200
donc ce qui est ce qui est pour nous un
record parce qu'on vous fait quand même
peu de démarches par rapport à ça et on
prend beaucoup de temps à chaque appel
et on n'a que deux jours de permanence
donc c'est peu quand on regarde sur sur
l'ensemble sur le 39 19 qui lui reçoit
décembre il appelle c'est peu mais en
même temps c'est quand même
représentatif d'un problème et d'un
phénomène de société dont il faut se
préoccuper et comme en plus on est là
pour réagir aussi par la loi par rapport
à la loi du 9 juillet 2010 qui mettait
en avant le délit de violence
psychologique et le délit de harcèlement
si nous n'existons plus
il yad autres associations qui vont
prendre le relais mais pas de la même
façon aussi pointue que votre
association et kz2 1999 vous avez déjà
fait vos preuves bien évidemment donc
agissez contre la violence morale
intrafamiliales et le stalking aussi un
valadon et ce trac âge des victimes on
n'en a pas reparlé ce soir mais
effectivement c'est un phénomène qui se
développe malheureusement également donc
association qui est en difficulté un qui
a besoin de vos dons l'adresse du site
internet s'est affichée pour entrer en
contact avec vous merci d'être venu sur
ce si elle va tous nous avoir reçus
merci vont passer au sport dans un
instant on poursuit déjà avec
l'opération de prévention pour les deux
roues organisé à elancourt c'était en
fin de semaine dernière par la police
nationale les motards qui concentre
toutes les attentions car s'il constitue
seulement 3 % des usagers de la route
ils représentent un quart des tués
le passage à droite le passage à gauche
interrogation surprise sur le code de la
route pas si simple après des années de
conduite jeudi dernier 30 participants
se sont prêtés au jeu du rallye moto
touristique à elancourt une journée
organisée par la police nationale sur
place l'ambiance est bon enfant mais
l'enjeu crucial alors cette journée
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'une action de
prévention action de sensibilisation
puisque sur nos routes comme sur
l'ensemble des routes de au plan
national les usagers de deux-roues payé
un très lourd tribut à l'accidentologie
donc le but de cette journée et les
sensibiliser d'une part aux dangers de
la route mais aussi c'est le but des
ateliers qui est derrière moi
actuellement à la maniabilité à
l'aisance sur leurs motos après un rally
de 80 kilomètres à travers le
département l'atelier de maniabilité
c'est l'ultime épreuve solidaire la
police montre l'exemple au programme
slalom manoeuvre équilibre et
anticipation une piqûre de rappel
nécessaire avec toutes les associations
qui sont sur place sur la sécurité
routière enfin il
et les sapeurs pompiers ça nous montre
aussi les dangers on peut rencontrer sur
la route sont donc qui nous donne pas
mal d'indications aussi sur les les
tenues qu'on doit mettre ou ne pas
mettre ce qu'on nous dit pas forcément
chez les tous les revendeurs de
d'accessoires auto moto je trouve ça
très intéressant par contre
ça manque il ya passé deux journées de
formation comme ça d'animation pour que
selon moi ça touche suffisamment de
monde et que les gens comprennent que
c'est important de pouvoir maîtriser la
moto sur la route quoi c'est
indispensable on est je pense qu'on est
jamais chevronnés on a toujours des
choses à apprendre et personnellement
j'apprends toujours des choses sur la
route l'opération lancée en 1998 et
renouvelée chaque année dans le
département le dernier bilan de la
sécurité routière dans les yvelines en
2011 enregistre 20 morts de conducteurs
de deux roues un chiffre trop élevé et
auquel les autorités souhaitent mettre
un frein